this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
star your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below
more on them in a bit
in the cruel and callous world of feudal
japan the harsh reality was that
toyotomi hideyoshi was born in nobody he
had no samurai lineage to speak of he
was supposed to be just another nameless
grunt who did the bidding of his lord we
weren't even supposed to remember his
name yet alone demon-worthy enough of a
biographics video yet here we are and
right from the beginning we get to the
heart of what made toyotomi so special
he was born a peasant and everyone
expected him to die the same way since
upward mobility was an almost alien
concept in feudal japan but hideyoshi
was intelligent shrewd and hardworking
and he made perfect use of all of his
skills attaining a status considered
unthinkable for someone of his station
he is now remembered as one of japan's
three great unifiers
[Music]
toyotomi she was born circa 1536 in the
village of nakamura in the awari
province just a quick reminder using
japanese naming conventions toyotomi was
the surname while hideyoshi was the
given name although he wasn't actually
called this until decades later when he
founded his own clan but for
simplicity's stake we're going to use it
from the beginning to make things less
confusing his birth name was hiyoshi and
he was the son of kinoshita yeymun a
farmer who also served as an ashigaru a
foot soldier from the lower classes who
did all of the military work that was
unworthy of a samurai one of the
downsides of being born a peasant apart
from the miserable living conditions
back breaking labor and short life
expectancy was that nobody considered
you important enough to write down your
history which means that the first part
of toyotomi's life is one
big old question mark one thing that we
are familiar with though is the violent
and bloody world that he grew up in the
warring states or sengoku period of
japan by that point the power structure
in japan had fractured completely there
was still an emperor and a shogun but
neither one wielded sufficient authority
to unite the entire country under their
rule instead power had been disseminated
among dozens of lords known as daimyo
who had spent the last hundred years or
so fighting with each other it seemed
that japan was destined to carry on like
this forever if not for the efforts of
toyotomi hirayoshi and the two other
great unifiers oda nobunaga and tokugawa
leiasu one thing that the sengoku period
did was create a constant demand for
military work if growing vegetables
wasn't your thing and you weren't good
at crafting anything then the nearest
daimyo always had a need for an extra
body to arm and fling at his rival the
pay was usually better than that of a
farmer and there was also the chance of
promotion so it's not surprising that
many saw this as their best career
option given that his father served as
an ashigaru it made sense for hiyoshi to
follow in his footsteps in 1551 when he
was around 15 years old he enrolled in
the army of a daimyo named imagawa
yoshimotu this was an unusual move
because it would have made more sense
for hideyoshi to join the oda clan not
only was it the clan that ruled over his
native awari province but it was also
where his father had served as an
ashigaro but who knows what hideyoshi's
motivations were back then ashigaru were
moroccan to mercenaries who were only in
it for the money and were quick to
change allegiances so maybe he thought
that imagawa had a better shot of coming
out on top even so after a few years in
his army had a yoshi had a change of
heart and in 1558 he left him against
employ and joined the odor clan which at
that point was ruled by the ruthless and
ambitious oda nobunaga
if you want an in-depth look at
nobunaga's role in the unification of
japan you can check out our biographics
video that we did on him a while back
basically he first fought his relatives
for leadership of the oda clan and once
he triumphed he set his sights on the
whole of japan which basically involved
fighting all the other major clans one
by one we're not sure what role toyotomi
assumed in obanaga's clan but he
certainly did not start out at the top
some sources suggested that hideyoshi
was a construction supervisor who
oversaw the repair of one of naga's
castles or a fuel supervisor who made
sure that all the various camps were
adequately supplied with firewood the
most fanciful tale claimed that
hideyoshi served as nobunaga's
sandal-bearer which historically was a
pretty important position since it
always kept the servant in proximity to
his lord whatever roles toyotomi might
have fulfilled it seems that he
impressed nobunaga with his diligence
and hard work there is one story
probably made up of nobunaga waking up
very early one bitterly cold morning and
taking a walk through his castle to find
that everyone was still sleeping soundly
wrapped up nice and snug in their warm
beds everyone except for hiyoshi that is
who had already woken up and started
working this kind of dedication brought
toyotomi ever closer to lord nobunaga
who gave his servant the nickname saru
which wasn't exactly the most flattering
compliment in the world but then again
nicknames rarely are tsaru meant monkey
and nobunaga called toya tommy this
because he had a small skinny body and
an ugly face other lords used saru as an
insult against toyotomi but he rarely
took exception to this it would not have
been proper since they outranked him but
his goal was to ensure that one day they
would be the ones washing his feet we
have to presume that toyotomi fought in
most of nobunaga's conflict starting
with the battle of okazama in 1560 where
the oda clan bested hideyoshi's former
master imagawa yashimoto however he
likely only fulfilled minor roles which
is why information of this period is
scarce due to a small stature it was
evident that toyotomi would not be best
used as a simple rank-and-file soldier
which is why in the years that followed
he was employed for subterfuge and
diplomacy which lined up better with the
hideyoshi's skill set during that time
nobunaga was warring with the saint clan
which was ruled by the young and
inexperienced sait taksiyoki he wasn't
really fit to stand in the grand shadows
left by his father and grandfather
betoya tomi this was an opportunity to
gain some allies without bloodshed as he
persuaded or bribed many of saint
samurais and minor lords to switch sides
to the winning team he also oversaw the
construction of sunamata castle located
on the border of the two clans to act as
a launching pad for his lord's army
toyotomi became quite adept when it came
to constructing or repairing castles
although despite the popular legend that
surrounds suyamata it was not actually
built in a single night it was effective
though so when oda launched his attack
on the sate clan on september 13 1567 he
conquered his enemy following a short
two-week siege of inubayama castle for
his role in the victory toyotomi was
promoted to general officially becoming
one of the oda clan's most valuable
officers
all right we'll get back to today's
video in just a minute but first here's
a word from today's sponsor squarespace
this is the age of creation everyone is
out there making something on the
internet you either got a great idea
yourself or you probably know someone
who does and when it's time to move that
project from your head to the screen in
front of you that's where squarespace
comes in it's the perfect web tool to
help you fashion the internet into
whatever you want it to be maybe other
hands-on type with lots of opinions and
ideas about what exactly your site
should look like if so very cool
squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical beers to worry about or maybe
you just need something functional
something that works with minimal sort
so you can stay focused on the content
and not the coat of paint just use one
of their quick beautiful templates to
make a website that's both fresh and
simple and once you're done setting up
that website locking in the name maybe
playing around with some of the colors
there are so many extra features that
squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
options 24 7 customer support really
everything you need in one place so when
you're ready to get started on the next
project of yours big or small evolves a
website it's got to be with squarespace
right now you can go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch your new site go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or domain and now
back to today's video
with the help of skilled generals like
toyotomi hirayoshi during the 1570s
nobunaga either subjugated or allied
himself with around half of the daimyos
in japan while also marching on kyoto
and installing a shogun who acted as his
puppet it seemed like his conquest of
the entire country would only be a
matter of time but nobunaga's leadership
came to a sudden halt in 1582 following
his betrayal and death at the hands of a
retainer named akichi mitsuhide with oda
nobunaga out of the picture his goal of
unifying japan now fell to his trusted
retainers with toyotomi hideyoshi
leading the pack the first order of
business was to punish akichi for his
treachery and avenge his former lord by
and large akechi mitsuhide's plan was to
unite the enemies of the oda clan under
his leadership and proclaim himself
shogun but he did not count on such a
swift response from hideyoshi he thought
that he had picked the time of his
betrayal perfectly not only was nobunaga
defenseless but all of his retainers
were off fighting in faraway lands
however as soon as toyotomi heard of
what had happened he immediately
understood that the longer he waited the
more time akechi had to consolidate his
position therefore he ended his fight
against the marie clan as fast as
possible and rushed his army to kyoto
just 11 days after nobunaga's death his
betrayer and his avenger met in combat
at the battle of yamazaki concluding
with the death of akichi and the victory
of toyotomi hideyoshi once that was
settled there was another important
matter to determine who would succeed as
oda nobunaga's heir toyotomi's
strengthened his actions certainly made
him a viable contender but would that be
enough to persuade all the other daimyos
to pledge their allegiance to him i
think we all know the answer that
of course not for starters nobunaga had
actual heirs sons and grandsons who
could carry on the odor name his eldest
son and his original heir oda nobutada
had died alongside his father but that
still left two other sons nobukatsu and
nobutaka both wanted to take over the
clan toyotomi did not feel like either
son was fit to take up their father's
mantle so instead of supporting either
one's claim he instead backed oda
hiranobu nobunaga's grandson as the new
leader of the clan since toyotomi was
one of the most powerful men in the
faction many others lent their support
to hiranobu there was one tiny problem
though since hironobu was still a baby
when his grandfather was killed
therefore although he was the n somebody
else still needed to make all of the
important decisions and
well who could that person be well why
not toyatomi hid a yoshi it was an
obvious power grab one that many other
daimyos agreed with but not quite all of
them if hideyoshi wanted the position
there were a few people standing in his
way first up was shibata katsui one of
nobunaga's former generals who supported
his third son oda nobutaka as the new
clan leader the two sides fought in may
1583 at the battle of shizugatake which
ended with a decisive victory for
toyotomi shibata committed supuku
following the loss while nobataka
surrendered and also killed himself a
few months later with one pretender dead
this left the other son oda nobukatsu
who also didn't feel like giving up his
birthright to an infant there was one
key difference though nobukatsu had a
very powerful ally tokugawa leiasu
another one of his father's former
generals if that name is familiar to you
that is because we've already actually
mentioned him as the third and final of
japan's great unifiers following
nobunaga's death tokugawa and toyotomi
found themselves at odds with each other
and met in battle several times during
the mid-1580s in what became known as
the kamaki campaign however they were
evenly matched both in terms of army
size and military skill and their
encounters resulted in a series of
stalemates fortunately both men were
sensible enough to realize that all they
were doing was helping out their enemies
and the pyrrhic victory of their
conflict would become easy pickings for
other daimyos who were gleefully sitting
back and watching them tear each other
apart therefore the two made peace and
tokugawa willingly became a retainer of
toyotomi nobokatsu did the same it
wasn't quite as willing but without
tokugawa's support he knew he had no
chance of winning so he hitched his
wagon to the winning horse and one final
detail now that there was no more
confusion about who the leader was there
was no point in pretending that the oda
clan was still in charge hideyoshi went
to the emperor who as we mentioned
before was a powerless figurehead and
got himself appointed kampaku which was
something like a chief counsellor or
regent the imperial court then bestowed
on hidayoshi a new clan name and only
now did he actually become known as
toyotomi hideyoshi the founder of the
toyotomi clan
[Music]
at the time of his death nobunaga had
subdued roughly half of the provinces in
japan now that the toyotomi clan was the
most powerful faction in the country
hideyoshi's purpose became clear conquer
the rest of japan this challenge was
more time consuming than anything else
toyotomi had the strongest army in japan
and also benefited from the endorsement
of the imperial court which conveyed his
mission a certain air of authority even
though the emperor likely didn't have a
real choice in the matter this became
toyotomi's main preoccupation for the
next five years also starting with
shikoku island in june 1585 the clan
leader invaded the island with a force
of over a hundred thousand men that kept
on growing as hiroyoshi added more
provinces under his belt the conflict
was fairly one-sided and within two
months toyotomi brought the whole island
under his control afterward he extended
his dominion over the eastern half of
honshu and the southern island of kyushu
by 1590 the only real threat to
hideyoshi's hegemony left in japan was
the hojo clan in the tsugami province
they were a formidable foe as they had a
large army and they were headquartered
inside one of the most secure
strongholds in the country ottawa castle
but of course toyotomi went this far so
he wasn't about to stop when he was just
a few feet away from the finish line in
may that year he launched a
three-month-long campaign to conquer
this final adversary it culminated with
the siege of odawara which was quite
predictably where the bulk of the hojo
clan forces were concentrated however
after a few months when food and supply
started to dwindle the enemy leader hojo
uyamasa committed seppuku and his clan
surrendered with his final victory
toyotomi hideyoshi accomplished
something that was once thought
impossible he unified the whole country
under his rule bringing an end to the
sengoku period of japan for the time
being toyotomi's mastery of japan was
absolute but he knew just how fleeting
power could be after all his former lord
was also on his way towards achieving
this goal before one mistake ended it
all for him therefore hideyoshi enacted
multiple policies that all sought to
limit the power that other people could
achieve so that they would not become
threats to him he nationalized certain
industries such as silver and gold
mining to increase the country's revenue
and prevent daimyos from gaining
monopolies he conducted a great land
survey and census and then a countrywide
disarmament campaign known as the sword
hunt in order to keep the peasantry
content subservient and most importantly
defenseless in the past agrarian
uprisings have become a common practice
so toyotomi hoped that these measures
would deter them or at least limit the
damage they caused some of these ideas
like the sword hunt actually came from
nobunaga who enacted them first and
hiroyoshi thought that they were good
enough for him to use himself another
measure he nicked from his former master
was to move daimyos around the country
from their original provinces the
reasoning behind this was that if a
daimyo was in a new place the local
populace would not feel a sense of duty
and obligation toward him and were less
likely to fight on his behalf hideyoshi
also imposed restrictions on marriages
between certain daimyo families so that
they could not form alliances toyotomi
was also big on castles ever since his
time with the oda clan osaka castle is
probably his crowding achievement as the
majestic fortress still stands today
located in the middle of the modern city
but hideyoshi was also a prolific castle
destroyer he knew from first-hand
experience how useful a castle in the
right location could be in battle so
once he was in power he didn't want them
to be used against him so he tore down
his fair share of castles lastly we
should talk about toyotomi's persecution
of catholics this was still in the very
early stages of japan's relationship
with the west europeans had only arrived
a few decades prior but hideyoshi was
interested in trade so portuguese and
spanish merchants were welcome to the
country however with commerce also came
christianity and toyotomi knew that
religious groups if left unchecked could
become just as dangerous and as powerful
as daimyos his former master had this
problem with the buddhist movement known
as ikea so hideyoshi became very wary
when he heard that missionaries were
acquiring significant territory
particularly in the port city of
nagasaki where the daimyo himself had
converted to christianity in 1587
toyotomi issued a decree ordering all
missionaries to leave the country but it
wasn't enforced since he was still busy
back then conquering the japanese
provinces it wasn't until a decade later
that he passed a new decree and this
time to show he was serious he crucified
26 christians in nagasaki who went on to
become known as the 26 martyrs of japan
a pivotal moment in the early history of
japanese catholicism ultimately though
hideyoshi abandoned his goal of ridding
japan of christianity for two reasons
one he didn't want the trait to stop and
two he had his sights set on a new
target korea
[Music]
so far toyotomi had proven himself to be
a skilled and resourceful military
leader but like many before him he
became drunk with power once japan was
under his dominion he wondered why stop
at just one country when he could have
an empire he'd looked across the water
at the korean peninsula and developed
lofty ambitions of conquering not just
korea but china as well so with that in
mind in 1592 toyotomi hirayoshi sailed
across the sea of japan and invaded
korea despite being blinded by his
military aspirations toyotomi did not
turn into an idiot he knew that war with
korea would likely mean war with china
since the two dynasties had close ties
to each other and the former was a
tributary of the latter he also knew
that the chinese army was a lot bigger
than his but he thought he'd picked his
opportunity well because china was
engaged in other major conflicts against
the mongols and several rebel groups
therefore the beginning of the war went
in toyotomi's favor throughout the year
the japanese forces successfully
besieged and captured numerous prominent
korean cities such as busan pyongyang
daegu and even seoul back then called
hansion it was promising star but by the
end of the war china had managed to put
out some of his own fires and was ready
to commit its army towards stopping the
japanese invasion add to that the fact
that korea still had a strong navy and
the tide began to turn in 1593 it was
the allied chinese korean forces who
started laying sieges to recapture their
lost cities momentum was on their side
until the second siege of jinju which
was won decisively by japan the japanese
samurai showed their viciousness in full
force here as they took no prisoners and
executed everyone inside soldiers and
civilians alike can send tens of
thousands of heads back to japan as
trophies for their lord who had stayed
behind around 60 000 people were killed
at the massacre of jinju which
represented the worst loss for korea
since the start of the war afterward the
two sides reached a stalemate and
entered negotiations for a peace treaty
the japanese army withdrew but talks
between the two sides weren't going so
well mainly because toyotomi's demands
were in line with that of a conqueror
and china would never agree to give him
what he wanted ultimately the talks
broke down completely and japan launched
its second korean invasion in 1597. this
one started off worse for toyotomi
because he no longer had the element of
surprise on his side but he was also
losing a second battle one that he had
no hope of ever winning that against
father time by this point hideyoshi was
in his 60s and his health had begun
deteriorating rapidly in september 1598
the ruler of japan was on his deathbed
in his castle in kyoto seemingly
regretting his decision to invade korea
he died on september 18th age 62 and his
last words were reported to be don't let
my soldiers become spirits in a foreign
land this created a tricky situation
regarding his succession because
hideyoshi's son and heir toyotomi
hideyori was just five years old when
his father died hideyoshi tried to solve
this issue by creating the council of
five elders consisting of five of his
most powerful daimyos who would act as
regions he hoped that this solution
would prevent one man from trying to
claim power for himself but it didn't
pan out one of the five elders was
tokugawa layasu toyotomi's former foe
and ally decades earlier tokugawa agreed
to seed authority to toyotomihito yoshi
for both of their benefits but he was
not about to do the same thing for some
snot-nosed five-year-old child he
challenged the claim and went to war
against the toyotomi clan but
that's a story
for another day so i really hope you
enjoyed today's video look if you enjoy
this sort of content we touched on a lot
of wars here then you'll really enjoy my
brand new channel war of graphics which
i will link to below and thank you for
watching
now just before you leave today maybe
look for something else to watch why not
check out my new channel called wara
graphics want to know all of the details
about some of history's most famous
battles and wars come join me on wara
graphics from sherman's march to the sea
to operation barbarossa it's got people
fighting each other or occasionally
animals we will cover it there is a link
below